thank you for joining us we begin with
breaking news this newshour from germany
and the berlin hospital treating russian
opposition leader alexei navalny says
test results indicate he was poisoned
navalny was flown from a siberian
hospital in an induced coma
on saturday he is a longtime opponent of
russian president vladimir putin
he fell ill on a flight on thursday
doctors in russia earlier
said that no poison was found in his
system
let's bring in our correspondent in
berlin dominic kane who joins us now
live so doctors they're saying that
uh navalny was probably poisoned
what more are they saying and what do we
know about his current condition
his current condition is that he is in
the coma
he is there's no immediate threat to his
life
but the doctors here in contrast in
stark contrast to the situation
of what was said by the doctors and
amster the doctors here
very clearly saying that what they found
in his system
is a toxin that belongs to what are
called colin esterase
inhibitors those are effectively that's
something which works inside the human
body inside the central nervous system
to control muscles in the body now they
are treating the patient they are
treating alexey navalny with
atropine which is an antidote they hope
will
work to counter the effect of these
cholinesterase inhibitors the point is
this is affecting his motor neurons and
that those are effectively the ways that
human bodies move
muscles that sort of thing the
interesting thing here is that the
doctors
in the charity hospital behind me
they're saying they don't
know what effect this condition
will have had on mr navalny for the
future they are not sure
quite when if he ever is able to recover
quite how full his recovery will be but
the thing to take from this
is the doctors are clearly saying there
is a toxic
a poison in his system they're trying to
treat it
they're not sure exactly what it is and
that is in stark
contrast to what those doctors in omsk
were saying those are the ones
who treated mr navalny first yeah and
the german government dominic has also
spoken about navalny's condition for the
first time since he was flown to berlin
but they're being very cautious about
directly blaming russia
yes it's interesting the governments
both of germany but also the french
government in the shape of
president emmanuel macron a few days ago
were very concerned about what had
happened to mr navalny and they wanted
answers they wanted to know what was in
his system how it got there
what could be done about it and that's
something that's
definitely echoed by the german
government too we know that haiku must
the
german foreign minister social democrat
politician who was meeting his ukrainian
counterpart
earlier today was speaking about the
situation regarding mr navalny
it's very clear that governments in
western europe in the european union
have grave misgivings about what has
happened to him
the question now will be is it possible
for
the specialists here in the charity
hospital to nail down exactly
what which of these cholinesterase
inhibitors
is actually in his system what's
important there
is that there are certain nerve agents
that's chemical
weapons which contain the sorts of
substance that would engender the sort
of reaction
that mr navalny has shown now there's no
proof of that just yet
and there are other drugs and that sort
of thing that
are available which could explain
the condition that mr navalny has right
now
but the fact that the doctors here have
been so clear about what they think has
happened to him
and the sort of antidote they're using
well it's very suggestive of what they
think has gone on here
thank you very much for that dominic
kane live for us there in berlin